nella scorsa notte una viterbese di 23
anni ha ucciso a coltellate il buon
gusto
secondo la scientifica la ragazza
avrebbe prima acquistato un cane
chiamandolo congo e poi del pongo
chiamandolo cane come cracco il
movimento 5 stelle perde una stella
michelin
i clienti dicono di maio non è più lo
stesso santa rita da cascia e musical
la prima al teatro della luna emozione
il pubblico con una doccia di acquasanta
e musica metal
buon pomeriggio e bentrovati l'anno di
sora ufficiale è scomparsa e non la si
trova più stavo parlando nell'ombra di
peter pan e nell'anima di cocco stiamo
parlando della dignità per tutti noi
ascoltiamo adesso il servizio a cura di
carlo ma di merito secondo alcuni tiri e
moderne la dignità ci avrebbe
abbandonato definitivamente nel momento
in cui e iva zanicchi gago in diretta tv
e antonella clerici lo ricevette una
chiamata da un'anonima signora che
urlava gran voce la borra tutti noi vi
devo dell'avvenuto e creiamo qualche
simpatica gif online ma perché nessuno
si chiese chi fosse veramente quella
signora che sprecava la cornetta e
soprattutto cosa volesse dire veramente
alla spesa tanto nella secondo la cabala
infatti ciò che la donna intendeva
realmente non era porra mammina
corrispondente al terzo set hero
dell'albero della vita al quale viene
attribuito il significato di
comprensione intelligenza che quella
signora avesse veramente compreso quanto
fosse vicina alla fine e stesse cercando
di avvertire la nazione tramite la prova
del cuoco
secondo gli ultimi aggiornamenti istat
siamo tutti colpevoli sono stati infatti
proprio i nostri gesti sconsiderati ad
annientare
questi possiamo annoverare impostare le
foto mezzi nudi su instagram con delle
frasi filosofiche sotto o su facebook
che i profili di coppia o ancora peggio
tutti coloro che contattano gli ex
quando si ubriacano ma analizziamo
meglio questo grande cerchiamo un
pochino di tornare all'origine del
problema quando resistenza della dignità
viene messa per la prima volta in
discussione dai nostri avi abbiamo al
telefono e docente di storia
dell'università la sapienza di roma
allora è milan che che ruolo gioca in
passato ecco quando si parla di dignita
essenziale ci aiuterebbe senz'altro a
capire da dove tutto ha avuto inizio
vi faccio un esempio si dice aperture
server e davanti al suo assassino bruto
abbia pronunciato la celebre frase tu
quoque brute fili mi
anche tu bruto figlio mio ma secondo gli
sceneggiatori di matrix sulle vere
parole dell'imperatore come me
grandissimo fan di anna tatangelo furono
questo potrebbe ribaltare completamente
ogni iter e moderno se queste sono
testimonianze preziose grazie per il
contributo ma rimaniamo ancora su questo
tema una nuova scopate scoperta è stata
fatta a borgata finocchio in
collegamento abbiamo un massimo jenner
massimo ti sentiamo si permettetemi di
mostrarvi come lo scioglimento delle
nevi ha permesso di rinvenire un
antichissimo fossile di dignità stiamo
parlando di un frammento della stele di
rosetta nel quale si può ancora leggere
il messaggio che una madre ha mandato
alla propria figlia ora permettetemi di
tradurre per voi la scritta in democrito
antico l'antichissimo fossile recita le
seguenti parole jennifer la prossima
volta che ti metti quel rossetto da
[ __ ] fa pure le valigie vattene
non abbiamo mandato nostra figlia
college per diventare una trucida grazie
generale la dignità purtroppo è da
grande assente di questo secolo
c'è però chi giura di averle intravista
una piccola scintilla del nuovo
capolavoro di marilyn manson si stiamo
proprio parlando di santa rita da cascia
il musical noi abbiamo la fortuna di
avere qui in studio il regista e gli
interpreti che ci parleranno di questa
meravigliosa opera ma che soprattutto
canteranno per noi non sono una signora
tratta proprio dal musical noi ci
vediamo dopo la pubblicità
a tra poco
[Musica]